quand on s'est vu j'étais vraiment dans
l'optique de vouloir mourir et oui
aujourd'hui j'ai des amis mais j'ai mon
petit chat qui vous oblige à sortir tous
les jours
c'est complètement différent aujourd'hui
que lorsqu on s'est rencontré
lors de notre première rencontre
romel hansmann était déterminé à mourir
en 2014 j'ai fait une première tentative
de suicide
j'avais 20 ans j'ai été hospitalisée en
psychiatrie je suis sorti de l'hôpital
géré fait une tentative de suicide il se
fait retourner
épuisé il était arrivé au bout de son
lot parcours dépressif
je sais vraiment comment le formuler
mais c'est l'angoissé
celle isolement le le retrait d'un
rapport aux autres
la psychiatrie les médicaments les
psychothérapies et même les électrochocs
était puissant à soigner son mal si
l'euthanasie nîmes est refusé
[Musique]
je pense que je ne pense pas je suis sûr
que je veux je passerai à l'acte
ce qui sidère oui aujourd'hui je vais
beaucoup mieux
c'est vrai qu'il ya un long parcours par
rapport à la demande d'euthanasie j'ai
pu ensuite à suite à sa rencontre et un
médecin qui m'a relativement bien aidé
plus de temps après notre rencontre
remet à consulter le docteur léon
constant qui se disait prêt à évaluer sa
demande d' aide médicale à mourir
moi je me suis positionné en 10 ans ben
si tu es en confiance avec moi si tu
pense qu'on peut travailler ensemble je
vais devenir ton médecin traitant et on
verra ensemble si l'euthanasie est la
meilleure réponse je n'ai pas dit oui je
n'ai pas dit non je dis c'est possible
mais on va travailler ça va je suis
correcte
toujours à mankono stress le docteur
constant est connu pour avoir pratiqué
de nombreuses euthanasies depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi il y a 20
ans il juge qu'il s'agit d'un soin
médical tout à fait acceptable quand il
remplit tous les critères prévus par la
loi et robert répondait à plusieurs de
ces critères mais le médecin a jugé que
son cas était spéciale à cause de son
type de maladie et de son jeune âge je
pense que le rapport que nous avons avec
notre réalité psychique et notre cerveau
est complexe il évolue avec le temps et
il est marqué par des traumatismes
d'enfance je pense que dans le cadre de
romain c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit et
ça ça peut être travaillée et avec le
travail on peut arriver à d'autres
solutions
j'ai trouvé avec lui une écoute que je
l'avais eu nulle part ailleurs
peu à peu contre toute attente remet a
repris goût à la vie
il ya eu une perte de points un regain
de confiance en moi je vis les choses de
mon appartement et je me dis que bassila
vie c'est ça ben je suis peut-être
d'accord de continuer
je ne pense pas qu'il ya eu un
déclencheur un fait précis jacqueline
herremans c'est présidente de
l'association belge pour le droit de
mourir dans la dignité elle connaît et
accompagne romain dans ses démarches
depuis des années c'est elle qui l'avait
dirigé vers le docteur constante le fait
que j'ai vu tout doucement roma se
dégage est qu'il a de ne plus parler de
suicide au cas on l'entendrait pas par
rapport à la demande d'euthanasie de
reprendre ses études j'ai poussé un ouf
de soulagement bien entendu cette
avocate et militante et membre de la
commission d'évaluation et de contrôle
de la loi sur l'euthanasie depuis son
adoption en mai 2002
au départ on n'avait pas nécessairement
penser à des cas de demande d'euthanasie
pour raisons psychiatriques
pension cancer on passe on pensait en
maladies
neurodégénératives et caetera et les
demandes sont arrivés assez rapidement
ce qui concerne des patients atteints de
dépression chronique pour lesquelles il
n'existait pas de possibilité de
traitement
la loi belge je prévois que la vie d'au
moins deux médecins et nécessaires pour
accorder une tana zip et celui d'au
moins un psychiatre dans les cas de
maladies d'ordre psychique remet
rencontré deux psychiatres qui lui ont
refusé l'accès à une mort médicalisé moi
je considère que la loi est bien fait
non je peux me prendre comme exemple
finalement 1
on m'a proposé autre chose on a essayé
autre chose et aujourd'hui ça fonctionne
dans mon expérience il ya peut-être une
demande d'euthanasie sur dix qui aboutit
à l'euthanasie parce que
les situations désespoir sont fréquentes
dans la société pour moi la loi est très
bien fait mais c'est une loi qui oblige
les médecins donc c'est une loi qui nous
honore sa honore le corps médical parce
que ça lui donne une responsabilité
énorme
depuis le début des malheurs remet soit
et surtout que sa maladie soit prise au
sérieux l'ugta d'asie n'était pas une
fin en soi moi peut-être que s'il avait
obtenu je leur ai pas toujours pas mise
en place directement mais je savais que
j'aurais pu savoir que si vraiment un
moment donné c'était fini ça n'allait
plus il y avait cette possibilité là oui
je pense qu'il ya des bases solides
maintenant qu'ils se mettent en place
pour qu'ils aillent vers vers une
construction une construction d'une
existence qui
pourra être heureuse
romain landsman continue à voir son
médecin au moins une fois par semaine il
en a besoin sa situation reste fragile
mais le risque suicidaire existe
toujours le moc cité est toujours là
donc il ya une difficulté de vivre qui
doit qui doit continuer à être
accompagnés on se reverra
ça serait quoi situation est alors en
couple avec un enfant peut-être un
travail qui me plaît dans lequel je me
sens épanoui avec des contacts sociaux
oui quelque chose d'avoir de positif une
petite famille un travail oui les
voyages et